let's talk about the whistleblower now
Donald Trump is actively putting
endanger the life of the Ukraine
whistleblower according to the
whistleblowers attorneys now I told you
that day that the Trump Ukraine
whistleblower scandal broke that I hope
that the whistleblowers identity is
protected because if Trump assigned out
who the person is
who's whistleblower report triggered an
impeachment inquiry of their beloved
Lord and Savior Donald Trump that
whistleblowers life is instantly in
danger and I'm not exaggerating when I
say that I'm talking about a real and
present danger to that whistleblowers
life and as if we needed any more
evidence about how Donald Trump feels
about the whistleblower and the
whistleblower sources remember that last
week Donald Trump was caught on a
recording talking about oh you know what
about when we used to kill
whistleblowers or sources or whatever
remember this recording basically then
person never saw the we never saw the
call and he never saw the call heard
something and decided that he or she
wasn't Halliday so I promise to spy I
want to know who's the first of the game
the whistleblower was the person became
the muscle Oh
because that supposed to inspire you
know what we used to do in the old days
where we respond the spies well it's
getting much much worse even in advance
of the individual being outed which I
hope doesn't happen the whistleblowers
lawyers have put out a letter saying
that Donald Trump is endangering their
clients life by calling them a traitor
by issuing threats of retaliation by
alluding to what about execution of the
whistleblower or their sources the audio
I played for you just now is referenced
in this letter and this is of course
completely countered to how
whistleblowers are supposed to be
treated in the United States there is
something called The Whistleblower
Protection Act of 1989 but forget about
that even beyond that there is the
tradition of how this country is
supposed to respect whistleblowers that
of course has been thrown completely out
the window by this administration much
the way that respect in support of a
free and independent press has been
thrown out the window completely by this
administration and as the whistleblowers
lawyers point out most countries where
the leader of the country treats a
whistleblower the way Donald Trump is
treating this whistleblower most of
those countries are not democracies and
it is very ugly what is going on
consider how backwards this is Donald
Trump said something incredibly
disturbing on a phone call with the
Ukrainian president you could argue what
Donald Trump was doing was an American
or at least did not put the interest of
the American people as the number one
priority people heard the phone call and
they reported it to the whistleblower
and Trump says that is called spying
this is someone both the whistleblower
and the sources for the whistleblower
these are people whose interests are
conserving the national security of the
United States their motivation is the
maintaining of the sovereignty of the
United States over our own elections
without foreign influence the
motivations of the whistleblower and the
sources are pro-american they are about
maintaining the systems and processes
that have been established in the United
States as the ones that we want
Trump is trying to circumvent that but
yet he's calling the people trying to
maintain these systems spies traitors
enemies all of this stuff now I do have
to go a step further here I get why the
whistleblowers identity needs to be kept
secret I hope that it is because that
person's life will be at risk if their
identity is revealed they are at risk of
death if their identity goes public but
we have to recognize that on the basis
of the way that Donald Trump has
bamboozled and primed his followers it
actually does help the Trump side for
the whistleblowers identity to be
unknown because of how they think they
will build a character around the person
crooked Hillary pocahontas whatever they
will smear the whistleblower and the
whistleblower not only won't be present
to defend themselves they won't even be
a known entity it will be Trump's case
against this unknown hidden person and
it will become part of the case for the
defense of Trump's view listen this
person won't even show their face I go
with Trump's view on this it's
disgusting that this is the situation
but sadly it is and you know that they
will use the whistleblowers as at least
up until this point anonymity against
them let me know your thoughts about
this I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show make
sure you're following me on Twitch as
well at twitch.tv slash David Pakman we
had a great live stream last night on
twitch I hope they'll catch the next one
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka is a
great service that i use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book PS jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform
you will never run out of fascinating
and critically acclaimed books to enjoy
and our audience can get a seven day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube I'm
putting a link in the video description
and after the free trial if you like it
you can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be Li NK is t.com
/p a que mas